شكرا ليال ونحن مستمرون معكم في هذه
التغطيه للاحداث المستمره منذ خمسه ايام
من اشتباكات في السودان بين العسكري هناك
نبدا من هذه التطورات حيث افادى اعلام
مصري بوصول الدفعه الاولى من العسكريين
المصريين المحتجزين في السودان للقاهره
واضاف ان الدفعه الثانيه ستصل لاحقا اما
عن الهدنه المفترضه الجديده التي بدات قبل
نحو ساعتين يبدو انها تسير كالتي سبقتها
لا اذان صاغيه ولا التزام يذكر وكل ما
يخرج عن طرفي صراع هناك هو تبادل اتهامات
بخرق الهدنه بينما ارتفع عدد القتلى الى
اكثر من 300 شخص ونحو الفين وسته وستمائه
جريح حتى الان
[موسيقى]
وعبر الهاتف تنضم الينا من القاهره رنده
ابو العزم مديره مكتب العربيه في مصر اهلا
بك رنده وهل فعلا واصلت الدفعه الاولى من
الجنود المصريين ومتوقع وصول الدفعه
الثانيه
اهبط الطائره القادمه من السودان تقل
الدفعه الاولى من الجنود المصريه او
العناصر المصريه في غضون الدقائق
الحاليه
على الساعات الاولى من بدء الهدنه بين
الطرفين الطائره العسكريه بحسب المصادر
لقناه العربيه سنه تكلمت
دفعه اولى من عناصر مصريه هناك فريق طبي
بينتظر
الجنود
ويعني في انتظارهم الان والضباط التي
تقلهم الطائره المصريه بحسب ما علمنا ان
حالات الافراد الذين تم نقلهم بخير وبصحه
جيده ولكن يعني لابد من ادراكشف الطبي
عليهم فور وصولهم هناك ايضا منتهى بحسب ما
علمنا قيادات مصريه عسكريه انتظارهم
ما زال هناك دفعه اخرى لا زالت موجوده من
المفترض انفصل مصر خلال الساعات المقبله
يتم التنسيق حولها
كما راينا وتابعنا اول امس الرئيس السيسي
كان قد اجتمع بالمجلس الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه وايضا اعلن ان مصر لا تقف مع طرف
دون الاخر وهذا الاقتتال هو شان داخلي
داخل السودان ولكن موضوع تامين عوده
العناصر البصريه التي كانت تشارك تقول
مشترك مع السودان في تدريبات مشتركه كان
هو اولويه يخص وايضا لمصر كما تعلمين
ان يتم الالتزام بها خلال الايام الماضيه
وبالتالي كان لابد من تامينهم خلال هدنه
او ايقاف اطلاق نيران ولهذا ربما تاخر
الامر بعض الشيء حتى يكون هناك تامين
لعودتهم همم الطائره
بالمجموعه الاولى صعبه الان ربما من
العناصر المصريه وسيتم تامين منتهى عوده
دفعه جديده خلال الساعات المقبله قيادات
كلهم سيتم
اطلاق سراحهم يعني الليله في فتره الهدنه
24 ساعه في فتره الهدنه ايضا المصادر
الخاصه ايضا بمنتهى
بحسب المصادر الخاصه العربيه ان الرئيس
المصري بيتابع عمليه تسلم الافراد
والعناصر الاسريه لحين وصولهم والاتفاق
على عمليه نقليم تم صباح اليوم بالتنسيق
مع الفريق تابعتي ايضا كما تابعنا جميعا
منتهى ان كان هناك بيان منذ صباح من
من قياده الدعم ان تم اقليم من مروي الى
الخرطوم وكان هذا في اطار التنسيق لوصولهم
الى مصر
الجيش السوداني تم يعني كان هناك
المعلومات ايضا
مسؤولي الدعم السريع اكدوا على عدم المساس
باي سوء بالعناصر المصريه
قائد الدعم السريع حمادي ارسل رساله الى
القاهره عبر مسؤولين مصريين بالتاكيد على
عدم المساس بهم وتامين وصولهم وحسن
معاملتهم كان هناك بالفعل وسطاء لسرعه
نقلهم وتم الحصول على موافقه من كافه
الاطراف بوقف اطلاق النار النيران وقفه
هبوط في الطائره المصريه لنقل العناصر
الجيش السوداني ايضا اكد على وقف اطلاق
النار بشكل كامل يعني او توقيت نقل
العناصر المصريه وعدم اختراق الهدنه وكان
ذلك لتامين وصولهم دون اي يعني اطلاق
نيران وهناك تواصل بين مصر وبين
كافه الاطراف السودانيه الان تفضلي هل نحن
نتحدث عن كل الجنود
الموجودون في
السودان بغايات التدريب انهم عادوا الى
مصر ام فقط اولئك الذين يعني كانوا
حصرتهم قوات الدعم السريع
الذين حصلتهم هم
تم الاعلان عنهم يعني لا يوجد جنود اخرين
غير من كانوا يقومون بالتدريب المشارك في
قاعده
وبالتالي ما علمنا ان هناك دفعه اولى
وهناك دفعه ثانيه ولكن عدد العناصر عدد
جنود لم يعلم في اي وقت من الاوقات حتى
يعني سئل اكثر بالمسؤول ولم يعلن اعدتهم
ولكن الواضح انه سيتم تامين نقلهم الى مصر
وكان هناك اتفاق وقت الهدنه بين طرفين في
السودان لايقاف اطلاق النيران حتى
ثقلان من السودان لتصل الى مصر شكرا جزيلا
لك رنده ابو العزم مديره مكتب العربيه في
مصر على هذه المعلومات اذا الدفعه الاولى
من الجنود المصريين الذي
سيصلون او على في لحظات سيصلون الى
القاهره وبانتظار الدفعه الثانيه ايضا من
الجنود المصريين الذين كانوا موجودين في
السودان
للمشاركه في عمليات التدريب هناك
نستمع واياكم الاصوات اطلاق النار برغم
انه الحديث كان قبل ساعتين واكثر من الان
عن هدنه بين الطرفين
[موسيقى]
صلاه التراويح طبعا
وفي الاخبار وزاره الصحه والصحيه في
السودان
ينضم الينا الان من القاهره عبر زوم السيد
المنظري
ومدير الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه شرق
المتوسط دعني ابدا معك سيد احمد المنظري
عن
الاخبار التي تفصلكم حول الوضع الصحي داخل
السودان في اخبار تتضارب من هنا وهنا كان
الهلال الاحمر الصليب الاحمر يقول شيء
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه
دكتور محمد ابراهيم قال لنا على الهواء
شيء اخر يعني اقل حده من الاخبار التي يتم
تداولها
شكرا جزيلا اختي منتهى كل عام وانت بخير
وجزاكم الله خير على الاستضافه طبعا
كما هو معروف السودان مر بسنوات من
الازمات والقلاق وعدم الاستقرار وهذا
بالتالي ادى الى هشاشه في النظام الصحي
حتى قبل هذه العزم بدات هذه العزمه
والنظام الصحي يعاني من نقص في عدد
العاملين الصحيين
حشاشه حقيقيه فعلا في النظام الصحي من حيث
البنى التحتيه من حيث الاجهزه والمعدات من
حيث توفر المستلزمات الطبيه والمعدات
الطبيه الاخرى كذلك المنكده للحياه هناك
حاليا يعني حوالي مستشفى في عموم السودان
وبالاخص تسعه في الخرطوم خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب الهجمات العسكريه هناك ما يقارب من
عدد 16 مستشفى مهدده بالتوقف عن العمل
بسبب الارهاق العاملين الصحيين هناك نقص
في توفر الكهرباء والمياه النظيفه وكذلك
الغذاء للمرضى والعاملين في هذه
المستشفيات هناك صعوبه في وصول
المرضى والمصابين وكذلك الجثث نقل الجثث
والمتوفين الى المستشفيات بسبب الوضع
الامني
داخل الشارع السوداني وفي الشارع السوداني
فهو تحدي كبير الوضع الصحي وضع يعني مقلق
جدا للغايه ما هي الاجراءات المطلوبه التي
يمكن القيام بها الان من اجل تسهيل عمليه
المنظمات الطبيه داخل السودان
هو طبعا هناك ادوار مختلفه لجميع الفئات
في السودان الفئه الاولى هي الفئات
المتنازعه عليها فعلا الالتزام بما يطلق
عليه يعني وقف اطلاق النار
لساعات والايام من اجل تسهيل حركه الافراد
من اجل تسهيل وصول العاملين الصحيين الى
المستشفيات من اجل تسهيل ايصال لمساعدات
والتموين الطبي اللازم لهذه المؤسسات
الصحيه كما ذكرت التي من نقص في الموارد
الاساسيه يعني لتقديم الخدمات الصحيه
يعني فهناك يعني يجب ان يكون التزام
التزام من جميع الافراد والفئات الموجوده
في السودان من اجل ضمان تقديم خدمات صحيه
خصوصا خلال هذه المرحله لانه هناك ما
يقارب من ثلاثه الاف مصاب تقريبا جرى هذه
النزاعات خلال الايام الماضيه هناك ما
يقارب من 300 وفاه ناتجه جراء هذه
النزاعات هناك تقريبا هجوم عسكري على عدد
من المؤسسات الصحيه هناك يعني هجوم على
سيارات اسعاف وبها مرضى وبها عاملين صحيين
فيجب على جميع الاطراف الالتزام بالمبادئ
والقيم المعروفه هل الوعد بان يتم فتح
ممرات انسانيه يمكن الوثوق به في ظل وجود
هذه الاشتباكات وهذا النزاع
والله نعمل ذلك على الرغم من انه كما
تفضلتم في التقرير هناك عدم التزام من
الاطراف المتنازعه بهذه الهدنه للاسف يعني
والوقت يمر بسرعه وهناك
وهناك فئات ضعيفه كالاطفال مهدده بمختلف
الامراض على سبيل المثال الامراض المعديه
الحصبه والملاريا والامراض الاخرى هناك
كبار بالسن يعني لم يتمكنوا من الوصول الى
صحيه هناك نساء ونساء نساء حوامل يعني
معرضات للوفاه بسبب يعني ظروف الولاده غير
السليمه في اماكن غير مناسبه جدا يعني
فيجب الالتزام بالهدنه كما ذكرتم في
تقييم بتتواصلوا مع جهات في الداخل مع
طرفي النزاع من اجل ترتيب مثل هذه الاوضاع
ام لا يعني هل هل تم التواصل
نعم هو طبعا منظمه الصحه العالميه من ضمن
مجموعه من المنظمات العموميه موجوده في
السودان هناك فريق متخصص واداره متخصصه في
الامم المتحده وتكرر بشكل مستمر تقيم
الوضع وهي على تواصل مستمر مع المكاتب
القطريه والرئيسيه لكل منظمه امميه هناك
تواصل بين هذه الفرق واداره هذه الفرق مع
الجهات المختصه في السودان سواء وزاره
الصحه الاتحاديه او الجهات المتنازعه من
خلال مختلف القنوات ففعلا هناك تواصل
ونامل من خلال هذا التواصل ان ينتج عن
فعلا يعني
التزامه بما يتم الاتفاق عليه في كثير من
المستشفيات بحسب ما ذكر لنا المتحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه السودانيه تم تحييدها عن
العمل لانها اما قريبه من من الاشتباكات
من اماكن الاشتباكات او
لاسباب اخرى بسبب الماء والكهرباء وغيرها
ما الذي يمكن عمله تجاه هذا الموضوع يعني
عدد المشافي سيكون اقل بكثير من عدد
الاصابات في حال لا سمح الله لو استمرت
الاشتباكات بهذه الطريقه
فعلا فعلا هو هذا المقلق ياتي منتهى يعني
طبعا كما ذكرت هناك 16 مستشفى
اغلبيتها حوالي تسعه خرجت عن الخدمه بسبب
الهجمات على المؤسسات صحيه لا تعمل ابدا
يعني وهناك 16 مستشفى مهدده بالتوقف عن
العمل بسبب ارهاق العاملين الصحيين هناك
احتمال المزيد من هذه المؤسسات تخرج عن
الخدمه بسبب نقص الكهرباء نقص المياه نقص
الوقود هناك يعني نقص كذلك في امدادات
الدم لتقديم الخدمات اللازمه ومشتقات الدم
والادوات اللازمه لانقاذ الحياه كما يقال
عنها فهناك فعلا وضع مقلق يجب ان ننتبه
لهذا الوضع ويجب على الجميع التعاون يعني
والالتزام بتقديم كل انواع الدعم لاهلنا
في السودان في مثل هذه الحالات منظمه
الصحه العالميه بتتواصل مع دول الجوار
للدول التي تعاني مثل هذا الوضع ربما
لتسهيل تقديم المساعدات ربما لعلاقات خاصه
في الداخل تساعد المنظمه في عملها والجهات
الداخليه التابعه لها في عملها ايضا
نعم نعم كما تفضلت يعني من خلال القنوات
الخاصه يعني بمنظمه الصحه العالميه على
تواصل مع الجهات الاقليميه والعالميه من
اجل تهدئه الوضع طبعا ومن اجل كذلك ضمان
وصول افراد المجتمع الى الخدمات الصحيه
ومن اجل تمويل النظام الصحي مختلف
المستلزمات لدينا المخزن لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه في اماره دبي
وحاليا يجب التنسيق على توفير المستلزمات
الطبيه طبعا كما تعلمون المداخل سواء
البريه او الجويه او البحريه للسودان
مغلقه ولكن نسعى من خلال بناء بوتان من عن
طريق البحر الاحمر كذلك من ايصال هذه
المساعدات وكذلك نعمل على نقل الخدمات من
يعني ولايه الخرطوم والمستشفيات المركزيه
في الخرطوم الى ولايات اخرى لم تتاثر
بقرار هذه النزاعات فهناك تنسيق داخلي
وكذلك خارجه على مستوى اقليمي ومستوى عالم
يعني بحسب ايضا المعلومات الوارده من داخل
السودان انه ثلاثه ارباع او اذا ما كان
اكثر من المصابين او من الذين لقيوا حتفهم
هم من المدنيين وليس من الجهات العسكريه
ما الذي
يعني ما الذي يمكن قوله في مثل هذا السياق
اذا في حال الدفع باتجاه استمرار الهدنه
اكثر فاكثر او في حال عدم استمرار هذه
الهدنه
والله هو هذا المؤسف يعني اختي منتهى
للاسف الطفيات والاصابات هي بين المدنيين
ولكن طبعا وكذلك داخل المؤسسات الصحيه
وداخل سيارات الاسعاف فهنا نناشد الاطراف
المتنازعه الالتزام
بقانون الدولي المختص بهذا الموضوع وحمايه
ارواح المدينيين خلال هذه النزاعات لكن
للاسف كما هو معروف لا يغلب يعني صوت
العقل خلال هذه المحن والعزمات وانما يغلب
صوت السلاح للاسف فنناشد كذلك يعني الجميع
داخل السودان ان يلتزموا بالاخذ الحيطه
والحذر وعدم الخروج الى الاماكن الخطره
حتى يضمنوا كذلك يعني التزام الاطراف
المتنازعه بالهده وبالتالي عدم التعرض
تعرضهم للمخاطر وفقدان الارواح الكثيره
يعني هذا ممكن يكون دقيق يا دكتور احمد في
حال لو كانت العمليات العسكريه في اماكن
المفتوحه ولكن كما نشاهد العمليات
العسكريه هي داخل اماكن سكنيه وفي توزيع
وقوى عسكريه هنا وهناك ليس فقط حول
القياده العامه والمطارات او غيرها فمثل
هذه المناشده يعني قد قد لا تجد صداها في
مثل هذا الوضع الا بتجاوب الاطراف
المتحاربه هل يعني لم يكن متوقع ان يحصل
هكذا في السودان عندما كنا نتحدث عن اتفاق
اطاري لعمليه سياسيه
بمثل هذه الحالات هل تفاجئون كمنظمات
دوليه ام انه دائما لديكم استعدادات لمثل
هكذا حالات لا سمح الله
والله هو طبعا يعني نحن تفاجانا كما تفاجئ
الجميع باندلاع فتيله الحرب بين الطرفين
على الرغم على الرغم من يعني النظر الى
المؤشرات التي يعني كانت موجوده على ارض
الواقع خلال الاشهر الماضيه توحي بان هناك
نوع من الشد والجذب بين الاطراف المختلفه
داخل السودان نحن كمنظمه الصحه عالميه كما
بقيه بمنظمات الامميه فنضع عده سيناريوات
من اجل ضمان توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه
كمنظمات امميه وبالاخص منظمه الصحه
العالميه وهذا ما عملنا يعني او عكفنا
عليه خلال الاسابيع والاشهر الماضيه تمكنا
من توفير المستلزمات الطبيه في المخازن
الموجوده داخل السودان ولكن للاسف حجم
الكارثه اكبر من مقدره وزاره الصحه
والسلطات الصحيه اكبر من مقدره منظمه
الصحه العالميه وخصوصا انه منافذ الدخول
الى السودان مغلقه من اجل يعني حتى نتمكن
توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه كما تفضلتي مع
ازدياد عدد الاصابات والوفيات نحن دائما
نقدر جهودكم والمعاناه التي تشعرون بها من
امداد المساعدات في حال في الدول اللي
فيها الصراعات والازمات الف شكر لك دكتور
احمد المنظري المدير الاقليمي لمنظارات
الصحه العالميه لشرق المتوسط شكرا جزيلا
على المشاركه
وفي نشره سابقه قال المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه السودانيه دكتور محمد ابراهيم ان
اعتاد الاصابات منذ بدايه الازمه في
البلاد بلغ
اصابه ووزعت على 29 مستشفى عدد المصابين
باسماء الاحداث بالطلغي ناري وخلافه 1572
حاله جاتنا في مستشفياتنا في القطاعين
العام والخاص ترددوا على 29 مستشفى عام 19
مستشفى خاص من صباح يوم 15 وحتى
مساء يوم امس
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اكد المتحدث باسم
الهلال الاحمر السوداني ان الطرق ليست
امنه للمستشفيات في العاصمه الخرطوم مؤكدا
على الحاجه الى مساره امنه بشكل عاجل
لايصال المساعدات
بالنسبه
للزوح هو طبعا حاليا احنا عندنا مشكلتين
كبيرتين حاليا المشكله الاولى اللي هي
المساعدات الطبيه او العلاج الطبي
للمصابين من النزاع المسلح احنا نادينا
بضروره انه تكون في مسارات امنه يتفق
عليها طرفيا النزاع لانه اطراف النزاع
الاثنين ملتزمين بتنفيذ القانون الدولي
الانساني والقانون الدولي الانساني بيحدد
حمايه ضحايا النزاعات المسلحه وان كانوا
عسكريين او
العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي هذا
المطار الذي كان مسرحا لعمليات عسكريه
خلال خمسه ايام مضت هو الان بهذه الوضعيه
وبهذه الشاكله بعد اشتداد العمليات
العسكريه والحربيه والاشتباكات بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع
هذه الصور التي تتابعونها حصريا على
العربيه والحدث لاننا وصلنا الان قبل قليل
الى هذا المطار بعد ان اصبح بسيطره كامله
تحت قياده الجيش السوداني وتحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي انتشرت عبر
الاليات وعبر المدفعيه وعبر الدبابات
الثقيله هذا هو المطار بوضعيته الراهنه
بعد خمسه ايام من عمليات عسكريه على اشدها
شهدتها هذه المنطقه وهذه القاعده العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه العملياتيه الجويه بشمال
السودان في منطقه مروي طائرات عسكريه حسب
ما نرى الان في الصوره لم تتضرر هنالك بعض
الطائرات تضررت هذا المكان الذي تشاهدونه
الان هو يقدم الخدمات اللوجستيه للطائرات
ايضا تضرر وتاثر بفعل الاشتباكات والضربات
العنيفه التي حدثت في هذه المنطقه الان
هذا المطار وهذا الجزء من المطار هو حيوي
يتعلق بهبوط بقيام الطائرات التدريبات
كانت في هذا المكان الان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تنتشر في محيط وفي ارجاء هذا
المكان تتمركز في مختلف الاتجاهات في
الاتجاه الشمالي في الاتجاه الجنوبي وفي
الاتجاه الغربي وفي الاتجاه الشرقي حسب
افادات خاصه للعربيه والحدث بان الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه السودانيه الان
تف بالكامل على كل مداخل ومخارج هذا
المطار والقاعده العملاتيه الجويه هنا في
مدينه مروي شمال السودان يوم الامس دارت
اشتباكات عنيفه على اثرها
غادرت قوات الدعم السريع واضطرت بحسب بيان
للجيش السوداني لمغادره هذه القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه شمالا بعدها
مباشره
تعاملت الطيران او تعامل الطيران الجيش
السوداني مع من خرج من هذه القاعده وكبدهم
خسائر فادحه بحسب ايضا مصادر عسكريه الان
هذا المطار بكلياته بكامله في يد الجيش
السوداني ويدى القوات المسلحه من داخل
مطار مروي الدولي ومن داخل القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه نزار البغداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث
نهاريه وصلتنا قبل قليل
لشوارع
الخرطوم بعد العمليات العسكريه التي
استمرت حتى لليوم الخامس طبعا وقبل عقد
الهدنه
التي تمت الموافقه عليها قبل ساعتين من
الان طبعا نشاهد في هذه الصور حاله
حاله الهدوء في الشوارع
شوارع العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
ونشير الى ان هذه الصور وصلتنا قبل قليل
وهي صور نهاريه لشوارع الخرطوم طبعا صار
في حالات نزوح من اكثر من مكان كانت فيه
الاشتباكات موجوده هنا وهناك الى مدن اكثر
امنا وامانا منها حتى الخرطوم بحري ومنها
مدن اخرى كما ذكر مراسلون في اكثر من مكان
وهذه
سوره
الفريق احمد عبد القيوم
وقد تعرض
للاغتيال هو وابنته عصابه ابنته اصابه
نجله تعرضت سياره
للرصاص في شارع الجبره الرئيسي في الخرطوم
اذا الانباء تقول عن مقتل الفريق احمد عبد
القيوم وابنته هذا الفريق الذي نشاهده في
الصوره الان اثر تعرض سيارتهم
للرصاص اصيب نجله ايضا في شارع جبره
بالخرطوم
من مدينه مروي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي اهلا بك معنا نزار وهل
الاوضاع كما هي عليه بعد ان تمت يعني
السيطره على المطار من قبل القوات الجيش
واعاده الامور الى الهدوء نوعا ما
بدات هذه المدينه مروي تستعيد انفاسها
وتلتقط مزيد من الانفاس
لاجل استقرار
وطمانينه
خلاف الايام السابقه التي عاشتها هذه
المحليه
الواقعه الشمال السودان
الجيش
مستمر في بسط سيطرته على كل المنافذ
المحيطه بالمطار وبحدود محليه مروي جنوبا
في اتجاه العاصمه الخرطوم قوات الدعم
السريع حتى الان المعلوم انها خارج هذه
المنطقه بعد ان يوم الامس نتيجه اشتباكات
مسلحه عنيفه واستخدم فيها الطيران الحربي
الان الاوضاع هادئه في مدينه مروي
المواطنون كثير من الذين غادروا المدينه
امس الاول نتيجه الخوف والرعب من استداد
الاشتباكات خاصه بعد ان شاركت طائرات
عسكريه في العمليه العسكريه التي دارت في
مروي كثيرون اغادروا منازلهم ومساكنهم لكن
حاله العوده الى
البيوت
باتت اكثر وضوحا خاصه الظهر وصباح ومساء
اليوم
استشعر الطمانينه النسبيه ارتجعوا هدوء
الاحوال خاصه وان الجيش السوداني القوات
المسلحه بدات في مشرق قوات التابعه لها
متمركزه في بعض الطرق الرئيسه
المواطنون الطمانينه وتقوم باجراءات
احترازيه
وتقلينيه للمواطنين الذين
فضل كثير منهم ان يشارك وجبه الافطار مع
القوات المسلحه تحديدا في مستشفى مروي
العسكري ومشاركه الافطار مع المصابين ومع
الاطقم الطبيه التي تشرف على علم مصاب
العمليه العسكريه خلال الايام الماضيه لكن
الهدوء الان هو ما يسيطر على مدينه مروي
التي تتابع عن كثب كل مجريات ما يحدث
من تطورات عسكريه سواء كان هنا في شمال
السودان او في العاصمه الخرطوم
ابقى معنا نزار لاننا سنتحدث اكثر عن
عمليه سيطره قوات الجيش السوداني على مطار
مروي والانتشار في بعض الشوارع طبعا ونحن
نشاهد هذه الصور يعني من الماساه ياتي
الامل احيانا متطوعون من الكوادر الطبيه
نجحوا في مساعده امراه على ان تضع مولودها
داخل سياره قبل وصولها الى المستشفى
وهؤلاء المتطوعون يبدو انهم من الكوادر
الطبيه نجحوا في عمليه
الولاده هذه هي بنت ولا ولد
[موسيقى]
امراه حامل قبل ان تصل الى المستشفى قام
هذا الكادر الطبي
بمساعدتها في وضع في وضع مولودها قبل
الوصول الى مستشفى داخل السياره
ونلاحظ يعني كميه الفرحه لانه يعني روح
جديده جاءت الى الحياه بايدي هؤلاء
المتطوعين من الكوادر الطبيه
[موسيقى]
ايضا عبر الهاتف السيد طاهر المعتصم
الصحفي مسؤول العلاقات الخارجيه في نقابه
الصحفيين السودانيين من الخرطوم بحري اهلا
بك معنا سيد طاهر المعتصم
الهدنه هل يمكن ان نقول انها ما زالت
مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه يعني عمليات تبادل
اطلاق النار منه ومن هنا وهناك لا يمكن
اعتبارها بانها خرق للهدنه
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين الكرام
بدات منذ حوالي ساعتين لكن
عند موعد الافطار شاهد عديد من سكان
الخرطوم بحري الخرطوم اعمده الدخان بصوره
كثيفه
ثم هناك احاديث عن عمليات حرقه في سوق
الخرطوم البحري
والكنيسه
والمحام التجاريه التي حولها اما بحسب
شهود عيان الاماكن التي لم تتعرض للحريق
تعرضت للنها الوضع جد سيء في هذه الفطره
ايضا قمنا بجوله ميداليه
محطات الوقود على قلتها التي تعمل بسبب
انقطاع التيار في مناطق كثيره تشهد ازدحام
الغير مسبوق يمكنك ان تشاهدي الصفوف على
امتداد كيلومت ايضا المحابس
الصفوف فيها
تتعدى لهذا الاشخاص يقفون في انتظار بضع
مرات من الخبز حتى يطعموا ابنائهم الوضع
الانساني اكثر تعقيدا الكوادر الطبيه
تحاول الان ان تستبدل الكوادر الطبيه
الموجوده في المستشفيات الذين ضلوا للايام
الخمسه السابقه يواصلون ايضا ونهارا ايضا
ما زالت مشكله الكهرباء والمياه في مناطق
كثيره في هذه المدينه الخرطوم بحري ومدن
اخرى في العاصمه الخرطوم
تعاني من الانقطاع الامر الذي ادى لخروج
كثير من المستشفيات
في عمليات نزوح صارت في خرطوم بحري بسبب
هذه
الاحوال اللي يعني الصعبه حقيقه
نعم يمكننا ان اطلق عليه يوما نزوح الاكبر
ولايه الجزيره هي الولايه الاقرب الى
الخرطوم
تراح الشرق الخرطوم
العربات كانت في ازدحام وصفوف طويله جدا
بعض الذين اصابهم الجشع
والانعدام الوقود رفعوا سعر التكلفه النقل
ايضا الى اضعاف مضاعفه كما يحدث في اي
ظروف مثل هذه
ولكن ايضا كانت هناك مشاهد جميله اثناء
النزوح
بحسب ما شاهدنا في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
عند اذان المغرب وموعد الافطار لدى
المسلمين
تقدم عن سكان الذين على الشوارع السفريه
بالخروج الى هذه الشوارع وتقديم الماء
والتمر الى المسافرين النازحين اعداد
كبيره لم يتسنى لنا
تقديرها ولكن
هي نسبه اكبر من سكان
مدن الخرطوم وخصوصا مدينه بحري التي تعاني
مر المعاناه من
القصص المتكررش
متقطع في المدينه يقومون بعمليات النهب
والحرق في سوق بحري والاماكن الاخرى هل
يعني
هل يمكن الاشاره اليهم معرفه من هم معرفه
او انه من المستفيدون عاده من حالات الحرب
مثل هذه بمثل هذه الحاله
وكيف يمكن وقفها هل يمكن للجيش ان يقوم
بنشر قوات او او اي شيء من قوات الامن
والشرطه
على الارض ما زال هناك الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع
صعوبه دخول اي شخص او حتى الجيش حتى
يتمركز في هذا الوقت من الصعوبه بما كان
بالتالي الامر يحتاج الى
توجيهات حاسمه من الطرفين سواء من قوات
الجيش السوداني وسواء من قوات الدعم
السريع
لحسم افراد الدعم السريع الموجودين في هذه
المنطقه تحديدا هي نوعا ما تحت سيطره
الدعم السريع مرات ومرات ينسحب بالتالي هم
المسؤولين مسؤوليه تامه باعتبارهم هم
موجودين في هذه المنطقه
وايضا مسؤوليه الهدنه
كما تعلمين سيدتي عندما تكون هناك هدنه
يجب ان يكون هناك مرافقون من الهلال
الاحمر من الصليب الاحمر من المنظمات
الوطنيه حتى
وتوفير الممرات الامنه الان المقصود انه
عربات الاطفاء ان تتحرك ويسمح لها دون ان
يتعرض لها
قوات الدعم السريع
السماح لها بان تدخل الى مناطق الحرائق
بتقوم باطفاء الحرائق حتى ما حتى لا تمتد
الى الاماكن الاخرى سيد طاهر المعتصم شكرا
جزيلا لك على المشاركه معنا وينضم الينا
مع الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
والطبع وبالطبع يبقى معنا من مروي نزار
البقدونس
سالم
حدثنا عن اخر اخبار حتى اللحظه هذه ما
زالت مستمره هل الوضع يعني يمكن القول
بانه افضل من قبل ساعتين قبل عقدنا حتى
هذه اللحظه في شوارع الخرطوم
نعم بالنسبه للهدنه المعلنه الان قبل قليل
استمعنا الى مضادات الطائرات في انحاء
مدينه بحري وكذلك هناك اطلاق في مختلف
انحاء ولايه الخرطوم بكل تاكيد هذه الهدنه
ما زالت
تتعصبنات السابقه لكن هي الاقل حده حتى
الان بالنسبه لما قبل نسبه الاشتباكات
وكذلك اطلاق العينه الناريه وكذلك سماعه
عدوي للمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه اصبحت اقل
حده من
الامس وقبله كذلك
رابعه فيها اكثر من اماكن اخرى يعني مثلا
في محيط القياده العسكريه في محيط
الوزارات والمؤسسات ام اي تحديدا
نعم هي ذات هي ذات الاماكن التي ظلت تتركز
فيها هذه
الضربات باستمرار لكن بكل تاكيد هناك سعي
جاد من قبل القوه المدنيه في ان توفر هذه
الهدنه ولو شيئا يسيرا من سير
العمليه الامداديه لكل احتياجات الناس في
هذا الوقت وهذا السعي يتركز في اصلاح
للمحطات محطات المياه وكذلك ايضا توفير
طرق لايصال المواد الغذائيه كذلك لايصال
ايضا الدعم اللوجي للمستشفيات كذلك ايضا
سعي من الولايه لتوفير بقيه الاحتياجات
مثل الكهرباء الان بدات تستقر تدريجيا في
انحاء الولايه وبدات بالرجوع الى شكلها
الطبيعي ليس بالنسبه الكامله لكن بنسبه
كبيره جدا الان بدات تعود يعود التيار
الكهربائي في احياء كثيره جدا كان قد
انقطع عنها لمده ثلاثه او اربعه ايام
متتاليه كل هذه الامور تدعو الى
ايجابيه الى حد ما او يمكن النظر اليها
بايجابيه اذا استمر الوضع افضل من
استمرت الهدنه بشكل افضل
هل استطاعت الناس ان تخرج لقضاء حاجياتها
نحن في الايام الاخيره ربما نكون في
الساعات الاخيره من رمضان شهر رمضان
الكريم بانتظار عيد الفطر يعني هل هل هل
صار في حاله حاله اطمئنان
سالم سالم ارجوك ان تبقى معي سالم راح
نرجع نناقش اكثر في هذا الموضوع المدني
ونزار بقداوي
ينضم الينا داود يحيى ابراهيم وزير الدفاع
التشادي
طبعا الوزير السابق
اهلا بك معنا سعاده ام علي الوزير هل
تسمعني
نريد ان يعني نعرف كيف تنظرون اولا لما
يجري داخل السودان الان من جانبكم وانتم
الجار الاقرب
اي والله شكرا نحن كدوله السعوديه صديقه
للدوله السودان ودوله السودان اخذ لنا
لدينا تاريخ
مزدوج نحن لدينا شعر في الحدود يعني شعب
لا لا
او سوداني
وباشره الكثير انه اخواننا
بدل ما يتحرون
في داخل مدينه الخرطوم ونتمنى
يوقفوا الحرب في حيث
نتدخل
ونشوف
نحل المشكله مهما مهما كلف الامر
ماذا عن الاعلان عن 320 جندي سوداني دخلوا
الحدود اعلنت عنها تشاد تم نزع اسلحتهم
ماذا حصل في هذا الموضوع
هذا الموضوع طبعا زي ما تعرفين انه نحن
لدينا سياده وان كان بيخش في بلدنا
الف سوداني موجود في تشاد نظرا لمساعد
وحاليا عندنا تقريبا
400 سوداني موجود معانا
فيهم وخطيناهم في مكان كليب
وسلينا منهم بحيث
نظرا للقانون الدولي
وناخذ السلاح بعد ما تحل المشاكل نقدر
نرجع في وطنه لماذا دخل
تبرير تفسير
نعم هل كان لهم تبرير يعني هل برروا لماذا
دخلوا الحدود التشاديه ما الذي كانوا
يريدونه
خوفا للمشاكل دخلوا علينا بهذه
انه هم ما دايرين
السوداني
فيهم جنوب وفيهم ضباط وعندهم مجرهين في
المستشفى
مع اي جهه تناقشون امرهم الان ماذا
ستفعلون تجاههم يعني انتم كما ذكرت سيدي
الوزير قبل قليل تتمنون ان يحل الهدوء في
السودان من اجل ان يكون هناك يعني وساطه
بشكل او باخر بس احنا بنتحدث الان عن 400
جندي سوداني منهم ضباط داخل تشاد
اتحدث عن هؤلاء ال 400 جندي سوداني ما هي
خطتكم تجاههم
اول حاجه عندنا مشاكل
تتواصلون مع الجهات السودانيه في الداخل
من اجل حل هذه المساله
في اتصال معاهم
هل
نعم
هل من هل من يعني طريقه من وساطه تفكرون
بها ربما بالتعاون مع دول جوار سوداني
اخرى من اجل دفع الاطراف للجلوس على طاوله
وانهاء هذه الماسات داخل السودان
هل هل من خطه او مبادره افريقيه يمكن ان
تعرض على الاطراف داخل السودان
[موسيقى]
الجنود السودانيين الموجودين الان داخل
تشاد
متى متوقع ان تسلموهم او ان يعودوا
بعد بعد استقرار السوداني
انتم كدوله تشاد يعني كيف يمكن ان تشاركوا
في عمليه احلال السلام الان اذا في هدنه
تعقد بين اطراف متحاربه بالعاده هناك جهات
خارجيه ربما تراقب ربما يعني ترى اذا كانت
الاطراف ملتزمه ام لا هل لديكم خطه ان
تكون تشاد جزء من ايه مبادره بهذا السي
انا انا هذا الموضوع كان تسالين في وزير
الخارجيه لانه هو
المسؤول
الافريقيه بالامم المتحده بحل المشكله في
السودان في بادره في بادره من قبل الحكومه
التشاديه لكن مسؤول عنها
كيف ممكن تصف لنا سيدي الوزير الاجواء على
الحدود مع السودان ومتى تحديدا يعني تم
القاء القبض على هؤلاء الجنود السودانيين
او تم يعني محاصرتهم
عن المشاكل في السودان يجوز انه يهاجموهم
تفضلوا ان يكونوا معانا لغايه ما ينهد
هل من اجراءات خاصه تريد التشاد القيام
بها على الحدود مع السودان
لحل المشاكل
لامن
انه نحن لديه صور مشتركه بين السودان ولها
2011 طبعا انا بدي يعني اعبر عن اسفي منك
معالي الوزير وايضا من المشاهدين الكرام
لعدم وضوح الصوت بشكل
كما يجب شكرا جزيلا لك على مشاركتي معنا
وزير الدفاع شادي السيد داوود يحيى ابن
عظيم الف شكر لك على المشاركه
واعود لي الزملاء من مروي نزار البقدونس
نزار يبدو ان الوضع في مروي افضل من الوضع
في الخرطوم مثل ما قال لنا سالم الهاشمي
ان الاوضاع يعني ليست
يعني ما زال هناك حال من التوتر
نعم في مروي الوضع اهدى وهذا ما يرجوه
المواطنون ان يكون هادئ ويمضي نحو الهدوء
التام الهدوء التام هو الان المطلب
الرئيسي لمواطني منطقه مروي والولايه
الشماليه التي وجدت نفسها جزءا من
معركه بدات هنا في مروي وامتدت
شرارتها لتشمل عدد من المدن من بينها
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مروي الان بعد
اكثر من 24 ساعه بعد خروج قوات الدعم
السريع من مطار مروي والقاعده الجويه
حاولت القوات المسلحه السودانيه ام تبسط
سيطرتها وهذا ما فعلته واكدته عبر تصاريح
رسمي بانها بسطت سيطرتها كامله على مطار
مروي الدولي
وان المنافذ والمخارج الان اصبحت في قبضه
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هذا الامر وهذا
المعطى وهذه التطورات على الارض
جعلت كثير من المواطنين
ياملون في ان تمضي الامور نحو هدوء اكثر
وامن اكثر وجعلك كثير من المواطنين الذين
غادروا بعض الاحياء المتاخمه بمطار مروي
خلال ثلاثه ايام الماضيه بان يعودوا مره
اخرى الى منازلهم حتى يبداوا في التجهيز
لترتيبات عيد الفطر المبارك وهم يتمنون ان
ياتي هذا العيد وقد انجلت هذه الغمه وهذه
السحابه السوداء التي
تظلل السماء السودان منذ خمسه ايام هم
يقولون بانهم اخص ضررا مما يحدث في مدن
كثيره
الخرطوم بحري كانت الاوضاع فيها نهب وحرق
وسرقات
زميلنا سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم
هل شهدنا مثل هذه الاوضاع في احياء اخرى
في الخرطوم
نعم هذه الاوضاع الموجوده في الخرطوم الان
هي بشكل كبير يعني اقل حده من ما كانت
عليه من قبل لكن الان المسارات الانسانيه
هي هناك سعوديه حديث من الفاعلين في هذا
الامر وهنا نتحدث عن المبادرات الشعبيه
التي بدات
المقاومه ومنظمات اخرى كذلك
بتنسيق مع منظمات اخرى بداوا في بحث طرق
لاجل ايصال كل حاجه لمن يحتاجه وضعت
مجموعات في الفيسبوك لتلقي الطلبات الحوجه
ومن ثم البحث عن طريقه سد هذه الحوجه
بتنسيق مع جهات كثيره جدا بدات هذه
المجموعات الان هنا في منطقه بحري بدات
بحري كذلك هذه الظاهره
الايجابيه بدات في لجان مختلفه في مختلف
الخرطوم هذه اللجان واحده من مهامها اولا
معرفه الحوجه وشكلها ومن ثم البحث عن
طريقه لايصال هذه الحوجه ان وجدت او رفع
هذه الحاله بمناشدات كثيره جدا الان هناك
مع اي جهات اخرى مثل الصليب الاحمر مثل
الهلال الاحمر
مثل وزاره الصحه مثلا نعم حينما توصلنا
معهم قالوا انهم بداوا الان في البحث عن
تنسيق مع وزاره الصحه تحديدا لكن لم يذكره
موضوع الصليب الاحمر لكنه ذكر وانهم
سينسقون مع وزاره الصحه في موضوع
الامور الصحيه والمستشفيات وانهم في تنسيق
الان مع هيئه المياه الخرطوم كذلك للبحث
عن حلول لمشكله المياه حتى يساهموا في هذا
الامر بما يستطيع ايضا لديهم سيبداون
تنسيق كذلك مع بقيه
العناصر او
اي شيء يعني ممكن ان يساعد ولكن السؤال
اللي سالم ونزار
بنفس اللحظه وانا بدي اسالك نزار
عوده الناس النازحين الى اماكنهم محاوله
المساعده محاوله فتح ممرات امنه كل هذه
الجود اللي تحدثنا عنها محاوله العوده
للهدوء هل هي اشاره على انه هدنه اليوم
ستكون مختلفه قطعا عن هدنه الامس التي تم
خرقها يعني لم يتم التزام بها على الاطلاق
نعم يعني هنا السيناريو في مروي يختلف عن
ما يدور في الخرطوم وفي مدينه ام درمان
وفي الخرطوم بحري لماذا يختلف السيناريو
يختلف لان الاشتباكات حتى يكون المشاهد
الكريم
اكثر احاقه وعلم بالطبيعه ما يدور في شمال
السودان
العمليات العسكريه التي تدور في العاصمه
هي تدور في مسارح متعدده وفي مدن ثلاث وفي
سبع محليات في الخرطوم كانت كذلك والان
اختصرت على مناطق بعينها هنا في شمال
السودان تحديدا في مروي مسرح العمليه
العسكريه فقط كان داخل حدود المقام وكان
داخل القاعده العملياتيه العسكريه الجويه
ولم
تضطر القوات المسلحه الى ان تتمدد اكثر في
تعاملها مع قوات الدعم السريعه
كما نشاهد على الشاشه الان هذه تعبير عن
الازمه الكبيره في مياه الشرب التي يمر
بها
السودان في هذه الايام
عززتها عمليه الحربيه عمليات الاشتباكات
العمليه العسكريه التي تكون في السودان
ازمه مياه الشرب ازمه كبيره كثيرا ما كانت
تعاني منها كثير من الدول الافريقيه لكن
لم نكن نشاهدها كثيرا في السودان سالم اذا
عندك تعليق على هذه الصور سالم الهاشمي
هاي الصور من الخرطوم ازمه مياه
[موسيقى]
لا لا
سالم الهاشمي في ازمه مياه الشرب في
السودان احنا عم نستعرض صورها معا
للمشاهدين الكرام فحدثني فقط عن نوعيه
الازمات طبعا في ربما الغذاء ربما الوصول
الى الدواء بس هي ازمه والكهرباء كمان
فيها ازمه اخرى وهذه ازمه مياه ايضا
هذه الصور لازمه المياه هذه منطقه الصافيه
في بحري وهذه البئر بارتوازيه في منطقه
البحر ياتي المواطنون لشح المياه الان في
المنطقه صاحب هذه البئر هو حصر هذه البئر
ليس لاغراض المياه اصلا لاغراض اخرى وكان
سعرها وهي الارض مرحله فيها ماء لكنه لا
يصلح للشرب جاء المواطنين في ظل هذه
الازمه
واصبحوا يغرفون من هذه البيت ويحملون في
هذه البراميل او المواعين التي جاءوا بها
ليستخدموها لغير الشرب واستطلعنا بعضهم
وهناك البعض منهم من اكل بانه ليس هناك
مياه فيضطر لشراب هذه المياه ذاتها وهي
مياه نؤكد انها غير صالحه للشرب بالفعل
نعم غير صالحه للشرب لكن اضطر لان هذه هي
الازمه الان هذه المنطقه منطقه الصافيه
وهي منطقه الصافيه
نؤكد على انها غير صالحه للشرب المفروض
انها تؤخذ لاغراض اخرى غير الشرب بس كل
هذا يدل على انه هناك ازمه مياه حقيقيه
بتعززها عمليه
الاشتباكات العسكريه ومره اخرى اعود لك
نزار البقدار الوضع في مروي احسن صح
افضل نعم من هذه الصوره التي شاهدناها قبل
قليل والصوره التي
اضاف عليها زميلي سالم مزيد من الايضاحات
والقى عليها مزيد ايضا من
الحديث حول تبعات تبعات هذه الازمه وان
هذه المياه هي فقط
لاستخدامات غير شرب وهذا ما يعقد من حياه
المواطنين اما هنا في مروي فالاوضاع
مستقره
بالشكل بشكل نسبي لم تدخل مروي وكريمه
وبنقله وحلفا وكل القرى في محليه مروي في
صدم ازمه مياه او نقص للامداد الغذائي
الان الامور مستقره في هذه المنطقه هم
يحمدون الله كثيرا على انهم في مناطقهم
وفي قراهم وفي المدن المختلفه لم يكونوا
جزءا من عمليات حرب مدن كما هو في الخرطوم
لم يشاهدوا سيارات الدفع الرباعي تنتشر في
الاحياء لم يشاهدوا المدفعيه الثقيله
وقاذفات البارود تنتشر في المدن وفي
الاحياء هم فقط كانوا يتابعون عن كسب ما
يدور
هذه اللحظه طبعا نحن مستمرون معك ومعك
ايضا سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من
الخرطوم في الحديث عن التطورات وفي هذه
التغطيه الخاصه المتعلقه بالسودان
والاليه الثلاثيه في السودان
اكدت على ان طرفي النزاع اعلن التزامهما
بالهدنه وسنشاهد صورا توحي بانه في هناك
حاله هدوء نسبي داخل الشوارع في الخرطوم
وفي المناطق التي حصلت فيها الاشتباكات لا
صوت لاطلاق النار لا صوت لايه قذائف
نعمل بان يكون هناك التزام بالهدنه التي
ستستمر لمده 24 ساعه حسب ما تم الاعلان عن
ه بين الجيش وقوات
الردع الدعم السريع عفوا
ومستمر معكم في هذه التغطيه من على شاشه
قناه العربيه انا اودعكم ونلتقي مع
الزملاء لنقدر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات